[Music]
often we need to transmit sensitive data
such as banking information where every
symbol in the message is vital one
mistake can corrupt the entire message
and no matter how we communicate we face
this problem one kind of corruption
occurs when a bit flips the transmitter
sends a one but it's received as a zero
or a zero which is received as a one
these are called errors another kind of
corruption is an erasure which occurs
when the bits are so distorted that
they're considered unknowns or blanks in
the message for this video we will
discuss this problem in terms of erasers
because it simplifies the main ideas
while some communication channels suffer
from less corruption than others it's
important to note that corruptions are
bound to occur
no channels are truly noiseless so the
problem communication engineers will
always face is how can we transmit our
messages perfectly when we know some
symbols will be lost in transmission
realize we all face this problem during
ordinary voice communication when a word
is misheard in a conversation to recover
from this corruption we simply repeat
ourselves technically this is called a
repetition code it's the simplest error
correction code for example if we have a
binary message it would be encoded
before transmission into two copies of
itself this might be received for
example with some erasers as follows
these erasers can easily be decoded by
comparing the two copies bit by bit
thus the message would be decoded
correctly this compare operation is
simple and thus can easily keep up with
the speed of communication
unfortunately simple repetition fails
whenever the same bit is erased in both
copies and because this is quite common
this strategy leaves us very vulnerable
to failure also it doubles the message
length no matter the number of erasers
we express this efficiency issue in
terms of code rate where code rate is
the original number of message bits
divided by the total number of Tran
minted bits thus the code rate in this
repetition scheme is 50% that means half
of the bits are needed to describe our
original message and the other half are
there to protect the message if we use
triple repetition the code rate would
drop to 1/3 as of the rate drops the
protection increases but there are fewer
message bits sent so a lower code rate
is a more expensive design since every
bit we transmit has some cost so there
is a balance to strike between the code
rate and the probability of failure we
need a coding strategy with just enough
protection bits to prevent failure for
any channel whether we expect a high or
low erasure rate while also maintaining
fast and code and decode operations to
solve this problem we need to be smarter
about how we use the protection bits
first realize that with repetition codes
each bit is only protecting one bit of
information instead we could define a
single protection bit that protects the
entire message from a single erasure no
matter where it occurs to do this we use
an encoder which counts the number of
ones in the message and then chooses a
protection bit value to ensure that the
total number of ones in the message is
even used this way we call this
protection bit a parity bit the sender
includes this parity bit at the end of
the message now consider what happens
when a single erasure occurs during
transmission the receiving decoder can
correct this erasure with a simple
operation it counts the number of ones
in the received message and so it knows
the erased bit must have been a 1 notice
that a single parity-check bit yields
quite an improvement to the code rate
compared to repetition coding however
the chance of failure has increased
compared to repetition
with a single parity-check bid we could
only correct a single erasure and if two
or more erasers occur the code fails
because there isn't enough information
to reconstruct the bits to decrease the
chances of failure we can divide up the
message into distinct sets and include
multiple parity check bits where now
each parity check bit protects a
different set of bits from a single
erasure we call each of these sets a
parity check set and as we add more
parity check bits we increase the number
of erasure as we can potentially correct
at the cost of gradually decreasing the
code rate in general the number of
parity check bits should be at least
equal to the number of erasers if we
want to have a chance of correcting them
all
however we face the same problem with
this approach the code fails if two or
more erasers occur in any parity check
set in that case the bits can't be
recovered in 1950 Richard Hamming was
looking at simple ways of correcting
multiple errors when transmitting a
sequence of bits his trick was to use
overlapping parity check sets which made
it possible to correct any two erasers
as a simple example consider a 4-bit
message and three parity check bits each
parity check bit covers three message
bits now no matter where to erasers
occur the code will always be able to
correct in this case we can't recover
the first erasure right away since both
black and blue sets contain two erasers
however the second erasure can be
recovered first because the read set has
one erasure and this provides the
information we need
to recover the first bit this cascade
effect where one correction allows us to
solve another is a very important
insight because instead of correcting
all erasers in one step we can remove
erasers in multiple passes or iterations
it's important to note that this kind of
Cascade effect only works if we have at
least one set with only one erasure at
each step otherwise it would fail this
led to a decade of excellent research by
many people who built on this idea of
overlapping parity check sets much of
this work was aimed at finding the right
structure for the parity check set
arrangement but when we extended this
overlapping approach to very long
messages with many thousands of bits we
ran into a problem this was because with
longer messages most assumed that we
could use larger overlapping subsets
but having many large overlapping
subsets turns the process of decoding
the parity check bits from a simple
operation into a complex puzzle this is
because when the subsets are very large
the chance of getting a subset in which
there is only one erasure is very small
and this prevents that cascade effect
from starting or continuing instead the
parity check bits must be solved using a
more complex decoding operation because
now you are faced with solving a system
of equations which becomes more and more
complex as the number of equations grows
but these more complex decoding
operations slow down the communication
process to the point where it's no
longer practical to use what we need is
a code with very fast decode operations
so we are left with a final problem how
can we extend this overlapping subset
approach to work quickly over very long
messages in a way that can handle any
erasure rate we encounter while
maintaining a good code rate in 1960 a
doctoral thesis by Robert Gallagher
discovered a new approach to the
communication coding problem which is in
wide use today particularly in cellular
networks and data storage applications
Gallagher combined to key in
the first was to use smaller
parity-check sets instead of larger ones
this improves the chances that many
parity-check sets will contain only a
single erasure and enables the Cascade
effect to happen this was key to keeping
the decoding speed fast over long
messages because it's faster for a
computer to solve many simple problems
instead of a single complex problem
which solves all of them at once
Gallagher realized that we need an
amount of overlap that is large enough
to protect each bit well but not so
large that the correction problem
becomes very complex he measures the
amount of overlap by something he calls
the density that is how densely the
message bits are connected to the parity
check bits with larger subsets we have a
high density that is each message bit is
connected to many parity check bits with
smaller subsets we have a lower density
that is each message bit is connected to
fewer parity check bits and this is
where the name low-density parity-check
codes comes from but aside from the size
of the sets there is also the problem of
how to structure the connection between
parity and message bits and that leads
to his second insight which was inspired
by the work of Peter Elias who had
recently shown that looking for the
right structure for large subsets was
relatively unimportant instead he used a
random subset arrangement this
simplified the problem compared to
trying to design an ideal structure for
the subsets and remarkably it did very
well and that's the key idea behind
low-density parity-check codes use small
overlapping randomly assigned parity
check sets this allows us to solve
erasers in a rapid cascade of simple
operations no matter how long the
messages or what the erasure rate is
while maintaining a fast decoding speed
but there is one last insight to
understand when it came to the actual
construction of these codes
recall that Hammonds construction
focused on protecting each message bit
with multiple parity check
it's in order to better protect those
bits in case of multiple erasers the
problem is this doesn't provide the same
protection to the parity bits which can
also be lost during transmission notice
that each parity check bit is itself
only connected to one parity check set
since any bit that is connected to only
one parity check set is vulnerable this
leaves all parity check bits vulnerable
this can make correction impossible in
some cases for example this would happen
when one message bit is erased and two
parity bits it's connected to are also
erased in this case we are stuck because
the Cascade can't happen and over very
long messages with many small parity
check sets this kind of failure would
become more and more likely to happen
the solution to this dilemma is to
instead view things in a more general
way and protect the parity bits and the
message bits equally that is we make
sure all bits message and parity are
contained in multiple check sets and now
we have everything we need to understand
the basics of low-density parity-check
codes or LDPC codes to see this in
action let's do a very simple example
now let's say our message is 1 0 1
recall that we chose our subsets
randomly to generate the code encoding
is now done by finding a collection of
parity check bits so that all the check
sets have an even number of ones this
involves solving a simple set of linear
equations now imagine our message is
received with 3 erasers as follows to
decode this message we begin with the
check sets that have a single erasure
first such as this one and we repeat
this process for every check bit until
there are no more erasers left that's
one way the iterative process can work
using low-density parity-check codes
it's simple fast reliable and can be
extended to messages of any length today
many communication devices use LDPC
codes and versions of LDPC codes are
being proposed for fifth generation
wireless systems known as 5g but
important to note that when these coats
came out they did not have a big impact
at first and were almost forgotten for
many years I invented LDPC about 60
years ago
there are Nelson those cellphones then
data transmission was painfully slow
expensive and error-prone mi t--'s main
computer at a computational power
halfway between a modern cell phone and
a coffee machine error correction coding
was a fascinating theoretical problem
that studied by many mathematicians and
engineers simple schemes were
ineffective but complex schemes were too
expensive for 1960 technology ODBC was
an interesting midpoint cute and
interesting to theoreticians but thirty
five years before technological
feasibility that's the way research is
and the way it should be hard research
problems take years to solve and should
not be overly dependent on details of
current technological capabilities
technological capabilities and research
projects both proceed at their own pace
and applications resolve when both are
ready thank you
you